je me fait capturer par la police
chinoise
ils vont me renvoyer dans mon pays pékin
6 heures du matin sont guy 25 ans et
mina 23 s'apprête à quitter la capitale
chinoise
la nuit dernière ces deux jeunes
nord-coréennes ont été hébergés par un
bénévole d'une ong sud coréenne en fuite
les jeunes femmes circulent avec de faux
papiers fournis par l'association
quand on est arrivé en chine
on a été vendus à des paysans pauvres un
handicapé j'ai travaillé dur mais
j'étais méprisé parce que nord-coréenne
[Musique]
victime d'un réseau mafieux elles
viennent de passer trois et cinq ans
mariée de force à des paysans chinois
les jeunes femmes acceptent notre
présence mais refuse dans un premier
temps de montrer leurs visages de peur
des représailles
ma tante a été arrêté par la police
chinoise après avoir passé trois ans ici
à bien cette autour du taureau leurs
modèles
ils l'ont renvoyé au pays et l'ont
torturé jusqu'à brûler sa chair après ça
j'étais terrorisée à l'idée de rentrer
en corée du nord
deux cent mille nord-coréen vivre
incognito en chine où ils ne sont pas
considérés comme des réfugiés
mais des illégaux le périple s'annonce
non et dangereux les fugitifs vont
devoir se fondre dans la masse
passé inaperçu pour les aider à quitter
le pays sans se faire repérer elles
peuvent compter sur nam ou 33 ans une
autre bénévole de l' ong sud coréen les
nord-coréens n'ont aucune idée du monde
qui les entoure avant j'étais comme les
pros
à 17 ans namouh elle aussi a fui le
régime de pyongyang
c'est vrai que la corée du nord a une
très mauvaise image mais c'est mon pays
canon ça me manque parce que tous mes
souvenirs d'enfance sont là bas et ça me
rend triste
son guillemine à sont maintenant plus
détendu et accepte d'être filmé le
premier contrôle d'identité va vite
réveillé leur angoisse les jeunes femmes
parlent chinois mais avec un accent
nord-coréen
on vient de passer un contrôle j'étais
extrêmement anxieuse vraiment eu peur
c'est un nouveau départ une nouvelle vie
qui commence
il ne faut pas avoir peur même si c'est
risqué
il faut qu'on mette tous nos espoirs
dans cette aventure mais ça passe ou ça
casse
mina et son guille entame une deuxième
vie une aventure faite de découvertes et
de rencontres
inimaginable auparavant vous pouvez lui
demander si elles ont déjà entendu
parler de la france
non
non c'est la première fois que je parle
à un étranger une fois j'en ai vu en
travaillant à l'hôtel en corée du nord
j'ai vu un américain j'ai vu un chinois
et un soviétique et fascinant pour moi
en fait de regarder un étrange et
fascinant mais dangereux la présence
d'étrangers est rarissime sur ses lignes
intérieures
de quoi attirer l'attention
aujourd'hui tout va bien mais à partir
de demain fait attention
ça risque de devenir plus difficiles et
plus dangereuses et vivante
le danger mina et son qui vivent avec
depuis plusieurs années a commencé
lorsqu'elle ont franchi la frontière
nord-coréenne avec la chine
on
quand j'ai traversé la rivière tumen et
le fleuve am noc
j'avais peur de l'eau parce qu'il
faisait nuit le courant était très fort
j'étais paniqué en traversant je suis
tombé je me suis heurté violemment à un
rocher le sang coulait le long de ma
jambe cousine d'aguilat
notre voyage en train va durer quarante
quatre heures et près de 3000 km
[Musique]
direction le laos au sud du pays
après deux jours et deux nuits nous
arrivons à kunming dans la province du
yunnan
il est 5 heures du matin s'arrêter c'est
prendre un risque
namouh cherche tout de suite des places
pour le prochain bus à quelle heure et
le départ 7h
payent déjà 500 yuans et du peyrat le
reste quand on sera arrivé
[Musique]
le laos approche mais le périple n'est
pas terminée
au programme huit heures de route
[Musique]
soudain en cours de chemin nous nous
arrêtons un poste de contrôle
sortez vos papiers ils vont vous
contrôler le stress nous envahi son
guide tente de faire diversion
voie papier
j'ai très envie d'aller aux toilettes
monsieur
vous arrivez dans pas longtemps
est-ce que je peux descendre s'il vous
plaît elle pouvait descendre mais ya pas
de colette ici le contrôle dure
l'officier fait du zèle l'idée que le
voyage va peut-être s'arrêter là si près
du but est difficilement supportable
pour son lit
finalement notre bus repart sans
encombre
hello
la fin du calvaire approche
les questions elles se multiplient
la prod que darty je me demande comment
sera mon avenir je me demande s'il est
tout ira bien dans ma vie ces
inquiétudes deviennent des phobies mes
nuits sont agitées
est ce que j'aurai le dessus sur sept
vit à la proche de la frontière
nous nous arrêtons dans un hôtel
demain les jeunes femmes rentreront au
laos mais sans amour pour elle le voyage
s'arrête là
on
vous
on se reverra en corée du sud ou aux
états unis faites attention à vous et
prier jusqu'à l'arrivée
prends bien soin de toi
[Musique]
au petit matin
mina et son guide quitte enfin la chine
grâce à des passeurs
deux rescapés de corée du nord
fugitif qui essayait de traverser le
fleuve j'ai vu des enfants battus
jusqu'au sang est renvoyée en corée du
nord et des femmes être vendus
c'est ce qui a décidé mon engagement je
me suis beaucoup inquiété de montrer mon
visage à la télé car cela peut causer
des ravages dans ma famille restée en
corée du nord
c'est pour ça que je refusais de parler
à la caméra au début tu n'as rien à
cacher tu as montré ta souffrance pour
que ce genre de chose ne se reproduise
plus les gens salueront ton courage mais
quand tu arriveras en corée du sud
tu dois étudier à fond pour aider ta
famille méthon pays ok
la plupart des gens qui arrivent là bas
ne pense qu'à gagner de l'argent et ne
pense plus aux autres ce n'est pas bon
de vivre comme cela
[Musique]
avant de s'envoler pour séoul mina et
son biberon de voir transiter plusieurs
semaines par l'ambassade de corée du sud
ne routes se séparent
nous ne pensions pas qu'elle sert croise
un jour
[Musique]
un an s'est écoulé depuis la hausse nous
avons perdu la trace de mina mais grâce
aux réseaux sociaux
nous sommes restés en contact avec son
nuit
[Musique]
nous la retrouvons en plein coeur de
séoul métamorphosé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui elle 8 en couple avec son
petit ami min-soo 25 ans lui aussi vient
de corée du nord
il a fui la chine quelques mois
auparavant pour arriver à séoul
les deux ont dû franchir les mêmes
étapes
j'ai passé un mois à l'ambassade avant
tienne car il faut avoir un passeport
pour prendre l'avion et met you all et
puis leurs aînés cas moi j'y suis resté
trois mois
moi c'était un mois et on était environ
15 personnes à prendre l'avion pour
venir en corée du sud
après j'ai été interrogé dans le
bâtiment des services de renseignement
pendant trois mois la première question
que m'ont posée les services secrets
c'était de savoir si j'étais réellement
nord-coréenne ils ont voulu savoir si je
n'étais pas une espionne
ensuite je suis rentré à nawa où j'ai
reçu une formation pendant trois mois
à naoua un centre ultra secret très
rarement ouvert aux médias
c'est ici que passent tous les
transfuges nord-coréens
là où se sont rencontrés sont guy
hemmings ou là où les autorités sud
coréennes ont préparé leur adaptation à
la vie capitaliste
quand on arrive on ne connaît rien de la
corée du nord au tout payant un loyer
gérer son argent
la langue les coutumes tout est
différent
donc on ne sait pas par où commencer
et c'est inquiétant c'est pour ça qu'ils
nous enseigne la culture sud coréenne
pour que l'on puisse s'installer plus
facilement suis gay
après sept mois sous la surveillance des
autorités sud coréennes aujourd'hui son
mii peut enfin jouer de sa liberté en
corée du nord
je n'avais pas de chez moi comme je
n'avais pas de maison j'habitais dans
une loge de gardien à l usine
là bas il n'y avait ni électricité ni
télévision tout ce qu'on pouvait voir ou
entendre c'était la propagande de kim
jong-un et de kim jong il a beaucoup
surpris mais ici je mange quand je peins
je dors quand je veux je peux aussi
prendre une douche avec de l'eau chaude
j'aime bien maintenant je suis
sincèrement contente d'autant que pour
elle en quelques mois à peine
tout s'est accéléré
[Musique]
bonjour infirmières caporal chef choi
soumis de la 960 troisième unité
militaire département spécial du
commandement de la garde suprême
aujourd'hui je suis ici pour vous
raconter des histoires que j'ai vécu
pendant que je travaillais à l'hôpital à
pyongyang
restez avec nous incroyable destin que
celui de son lit deux mois seulement
après son arrivée à séoul
la rescapée du régime de pyongyang est
devenue chroniqueuse d'une émission de
télévision dans ce talk show les
intervenants tous nord-coréen racontent
leur passé de l'autre côté de la
frontière en décembre 2012
mon père est décédé et nous n'avions
plus d'argent c'était que j'étais dans
une situation désespérée j'ai suivi une
femme et nous avons traversé le fleuve
pour aller en chine
très vite j'ai été capturés par des
trafiquants d'organes
ils discutaient de combien coûtait un
rat j'étais terrifiée je me suis enfui
et caché pendant trois jours dans un
champ de maïs mais qui étaient engourdis
par le froid et j'ai fait mes besoins
sur moi récit poignant reconstitution et
mises en scènes larmoyantes l'émission
fascine les téléspectateurs
[Musique]
après je me suis dit tu vas survivre
avec ce programme sont guy à trouver un
travail et une certaine notoriété sur la
route vers son domicile
la jeune femme fraîchement arrivé
s'amuse encore des différences entre le
nord et le sud
impossible de voir des bouchons en corée
du nord même si on souhaite marquer car
il n'y a pas de voiture si tu veux voir
un bouchon c'est quand un pousse pousse
certains passants il n'y a pas de
bouchon avec des voitures
son billet son fiancé habite hlm en
banlieue désormais libre est connu la
jeune femme craint pourtant toujours
pour sa sécurité
si jamais vous avez filmé le bâtiment il
faudra l'effacer en fait il n'y a aucun
souci pour les autres endroits mais
l'avenir toute ma vie se fera ici
la corée du sud est un pays développé
on peut repérer facilement ou une
personne habite par le numéro deux
bâtiments et cette information va
certainement remonter jusqu'en corée du
nord
voilà c'est chez moi j'ai mes idées
hockey euros nos lectrices
c'est un modeste appartement mais la vue
est magnifique
alors arrivé en corée du sud les
transfuges nord-coréens reçoivent
l'équivalent de dix mille euros par
personne et voit le loyer de leur
logement social payé à vis des avantages
conséquents mais pour son lit sa
formidable épopée garde un goût bien
amer on rêve était d'être chez moi avec
ma famille mais en mai dernier j'ai
appris que ma mère était décédée colo
mon rêve s'est éteint la seule famille
qui me reste est mon grand frère
j'étais complètement effondré quand j'ai
appris la mort de ma mère j'ai survécu
tant d'épreuves avec beaucoup de
difficultés en espérant qu'un jour on
serait heureux
même en étant pauvre je commençais à
peine à me refaire une vie ici et elle
est morte colonies je voulais vraiment
tout abandonner je me suis demandé pour
qui et pourquoi je devais continuer à
vivre
nous quittons sont gris
nous ne savions pas quelle serait
impossible à joindre pendant deux jours
la jeune femme a été interrogée par les
services de renseignement après notre
tournage
officiellement il lui a été conseillé de
ne plus nous parler
il faut dire que les tensions
géopolitiques sont montées d'un cran
depuis l'été dernier les autorités sud
coréennes sont sur les dents et les
citoyens tendu officiellement on est
toujours en guerre est ce que je pense
des nord-coréens
ce sont des fils de public
kim jong-un et ses copains c'est
vraiment des sales types
il faut les culs et se débarrasser d'eux
c'est pour ça que la chine la russie les
grandes puissances doivent lui parler
car sinon ça va péter
à séoul l'armée multiplie les opérations
dites antiterroristes
les craintes d'une cinquième colonne
nord coréennes n'ont jamais été aussi
exacerbé d'autant qu'un événement a
récemment ravivé les suspicions sur la
communauté des réfugiés 19 juillet
dernier les journaux télévisés ouvre
avec l'histoire rocambolesque d'une star
de la télévision sud coréenne elle aussi
transfuge du nord retourner à pyongyang
j'ai fui pour la corée du sud avec
l'illusion
l'idée des voiliers que je mangerai
mieux et que je gagnerais beaucoup
d'argent mais la corée du sud ce n'est
pas du tout ce que j'imaginais celle à
qui tout réussissait
décrite en habit traditionnel proche des
larmes
l'enfer qu'elle aurait vécu en corée du
sud ce que vivent les femmes comme moi
qui ont trahi leur mère patrie
c'est une épreuve physique et mentale
dans cette société sud coréenne où tout
est guidé par l'argent at elle subi des
pressions des menaces sur sa famille
pour rentrer au nord at elle été enlevé
par les services secrets nord coréens ou
est elle rentrée de son plein gré les
spéculations les plus folles circulent
et alimente la défiance envers la
communauté des réfugiés
[Musique]
entre 2000 et 2500 d'entre eux arrivent
en corée du sud chaque année si certains
retournent bien au nord
il constitue encore une infime minorité
pour ceux qui restent pas facile de
toujours bien s'intégrer dans une
société sud coréenne très matérialiste
et individualiste
avant notre départ de séoul sont guy a
finalement accepté de nous revoir une
dernière fois
loin de chez elle
nous la retrouvons dans un bowling du
centre-ville avec ses amis tous réfugiés
nord coréens
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous pouvez vous amuser comme
ça en corée du nord
là bas il n'y a pas d'équipements
modernes comme les karaokés les bowling
et les boîtes de nuit
ce n'est pas comme ici au nord si on
veut s'amuser on se retrouve entre nous
on bavarde et on danse
plancha
pourquoi est-ce que vous restez entre
nord-coréen
comme on est sans famille on se sent
seul
entre réfugiés nord-coréens on se
comprend bien
car ce qu'on partage la même expérience
les mêmes souvenirs les sud coréens ne
peuvent pas comprendre ce genre de
choses
tout est différent ici le caractère des
gens la culture
c'est ça qui est difficile
[Musique]
par exemple quand j'allais cueillir des
herbes sauvages avec mon père
c'est ce type de chose qui me manque
vraiment
et
est ce que tu pourrais retourner en
corée du nord
retourner là bas même si ça me manque
énormément
je ne veux surtout pas y retourner ce
serait comme creuser ma propre tombe
donc pourquoi vouloir y retourner ravel
ouais
sangay a réussi son pari
mais combien sont ils à tenter de fuir
chaque année la corée du nord
une certitude depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de kim jong-un les contrôles aux
frontières se sont renforcés pour les
fugitifs nord-coréen jamais le prix de
la liberté n'a été aussi élevé
[Musique]